To many young Americans, suburbs are
boring, economically stagnant, socially
monolithic places filled with
Republicans. But data from AEI's Survey on
Community and Society shows that suburbs
are actually politically diverse places
where younger Americans have vibrant
social lives and dynamic economic
opportunities. 21% of suburbanites are
liberal, and 16% are conservative. Most
suburbanites fall in the middle of the
ideological spectrum. 85% of 18- to
29-year-olds who live in the suburbs say that
they are living in a good or excellent
place. In contrast, only 70% of younger
urbanites rate their cities as good or
excellent places to live. Young suburbanites are also more likely to
regularly talk to their neighbors,
compared to those in cities. And when it
comes to the economy, the attitudes of
younger Americans toward their finances
and career are as bullish in the suburbs
as they are in the cities. The data is
clear: Younger Americans thrive socially
and economically in suburbs, which offer
space, safety, convenience and political
diversity.
Would you like to live in an
urban, suburban, or rural area? Let us know
in our poll. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.